ball to the Siberian Husky is remembered
for leading a team of sled dogs to
deliver medicine that saved the town of
Nome Alaska from a deadly epidemic he
became a national hero and his photo is
on the front page of every newspaper in
the country a statue was erected in his
honor in Central Park in 1925 and it is
still one of the most beloved tourist
attractions to this very day many of you
might have seen the animated film by
Universal Pictures and that might be all
you know about Balto but the true story
is far more dramatic than what you ever
learned from cartoons and children's
books and in the video today we're
bringing you the story of Balto the
canine hero our story begins in the
remote town of Nome Alaska in the 1890s
the Nome Gold Rush brought prospectors
to this small town in the hopes of
making it rich there were no paved roads
so it was incredibly difficult people to
get around especially in the winter many
of the people who moved to Nome had to
adjust the life in Alaska and they
became a very tight-knit community these
people they had a lot of respect for one
another because they were all managing
to survive in the American wilderness if
anyone was struggling neighbors helped
one another out without hesitation and
it really fostered a close-knit
community a norwegian man named leon
hard Cipolla and a dog kennel in Nome
Sao Paulo is credited for being the
first man to introduce Russia's working
dog breed from Siberia to the United
States and they later got the name
Siberian Husky these dogs became so
popular in Alaska that he decided to
breed them for a living he was only
interested in breeding dogs that were
light and were fast he became one of the
first men to participate in competitive
dogsled racing in the United States one
of the many puppies that was born in
Savannah's kennel was named Balto he was
born with brown eyes and black fur with
white socks on his two front legs Balto
was apparently too large he was
considered a scrub dog supernal had him
neutered right away because he was
deemed to be far too inferior to pass on
his DNA Balto was born between the years
1919 and 1923 but no one can be quite
sure of the exact date
Zavala essentially was breeding so many
dogs that he didn't really keep
crack of every puppy that he declared a
reject for all of the other dogs that
did not suit his needs Apollo would rent
them out to members of the community to
use for pulling their dog sleds in the
winter dog sleds became the only option
for traveling out of towns a trade gold
for supplies since so many men traveled
to Nome looking for jobs in the mining
industry so Paulo was able to make a
fortune renting out as well as selling
his docks cEPAL --is favorite husky was
called togo he was considered to be a
perfect husky specimen who was
incredibly light and muscular as the
story goes Togo was so fast that he
could race a train and win so spoiler he
but all of his time and energy into
training this favorite dog of his a man
named Gunnar Carson had moved from
Norway to Nome Alaska to take part in
the gold rush he paid to rents upon his
dogs to transport supplies that many
were working in the gold mines there is
no record of why cussin chose Balto to
be his lead dog but most people believe
it was because he felt some kind of
connection from the start
most mushers choose a dog to lead that
they know they can trust he saw
something special in Balto and the
decision to take him home it was one day
gonna save his life
Nome was having one of the coldest
winters on record temperatures were
reaching minus 50 degrees Fahrenheit
which is minus 45 degrees Celsius winds
were 50 miles or around 80 kilometers
per hour
there were several terrible blizzards
that made travel conditions impossible
and most people had no choice but to
isolate themselves in their homes and
just stay by the fireplace in December
of 1924 a record number of children were
going to the only doctor in town
Curtis Welch at first dr. Welch thought
that these children simply had a sore
throat and their parents they tried to
nurse them back to health over the
holidays a few weeks later in January of
1925 two children unfortunately died it
was at this point that dr. Welch
realized that this was actually a highly
contagious disease called diphtheria and
had an infected most of the children in
town the native Inuit children were
affected the worst because diphtheria
was a white man's disease this illness
was nicknamed the strangling angel
because the inside of the throat begins
to turn to leather and people can no
longer breathe or swallow children were
far more susceptible to catching
diphtheria than adults so parents were
watching helplessly as their sons and
daughters were slowly choking to death
dr. Welch announced that all of the
children who were infected needed to be
placed in quarantine in order to prevent
an epidemic
the cure for diphtheria it existed but
Nome was not equipped to treat such a
massive outbreak they needed a medicine
called antitoxin serum since dr. Welch
and his four nurses were the only
medical professionals in town they were
working around the clock to treat those
children the total population of Nome
was just 10,000 people and even after
placing the infected under quarantine
was already too late more people they
were getting sick every single day
everyone was afraid that if the outbreak
was not contained all of the children
may die and it may spread to the adults
as well on January the 22nd 1925 dr.
Welch sent out dozens of telegrams to
doctors around Alaska and even sent a
message to Washington DC hoping for the
help to get enough antitoxin they were
eager to help but the issue was delivery
the winds were far too strong for a
plane to travel through that weather and
there was too much ice for a ship to
reach the harbor the nearest city where
medicine could be delivered was
Anchorage but the train stopped in a
town called nanano which was 674 miles
away from Nome the only choice was to
take sled dogs
the snowy editor on trail which was
normally a 15 to 20 day journey there
were plenty of obstacles in the way that
slowed down such a journey mountains
steep crevices and the frozen Yukon
River alaska's territorial governor
scott bone approved the plan for the
best mushers to participate in a relay
to guide their teams of sled dogs the
plan was for 20 men and 150 dogs to wait
at checkpoints where they would pass off
the antitoxin to the next team say they
were able to transport the medicine as
quickly and efficiently as possible the
first man to pick up the antitoxin at
the train station in nanano was named
Wild Bill Shannon he traveled for 24
hours straight in minus 60 degree
weather to get to the first checkpoint
another of the mushers bill McCarty came
prepared with little moccasins for his
dog's feet so that they wouldn't have to
walk on the ice with their bare paws
Leonhard Seppala
volunteered to take the most dangerous
part of the journey since he had the
most experience but he was very
concerned with going fast and ordering
his dog to go as fast as he could just
like he would in a race he saw a man
called Henry Ivanov stopped on the trail
because he was struggling with
disobedient dogs
so Paula chose to ignore him and sped
past instead of offering help
Ivanov had to run after separa shouting
the serum the serum I have it here
thankfully cipolla hurt him and he was
able to turn his sled around and pick up
the medicine but his need for speed
very nearly blew the entire mission
since dr. Welch should send telegrams
all over the country a few days earlier
stories of the epidemic were being
printed in newspapers in the lower 48
states this story it was gripping and it
was tragic and it could have been right
out of a novel unbeknownst to the 20 men
people all over the United States began
to hope and pray that they would make it
just days before this happens hardly
anyone had even heard of Nome Alaska
but once they knew so many young lives
were at stake everyone was rooting for
them
gonna Carson had taken the editor on
trail together with Balto several times
on their supply run so he volunteered to
be one of the 20 men that helped
retrieve the medicine unlike Leonard
separa and the other men Carson did not
compete in dog racing also was his pet
when they weren't working together
Carson was very quiet and shy around
other people so Balto was his best
friends and he knew he could rely on him
Carson was considered to be a novice
compared to the rest of the crew
therefore he was given one of the
easiest legs of the trail Balto and
Carson really did lead a team of
underdogs in more ways than one but no
one could predict what was gonna happen
next
while gana Carson was on his leg of the
journey a terrible storm began each one
of the checkpoint stations received a
message that the serum run was
temporarily canceled because it was too
dangerous but Carson was already in the
wilderness with all of the antitoxin
when the blizzard hit he obviously had
no way of getting the memo also there
was no air for him to take shelter until
the storm blew over the blizzard caused
a white house Carson could not even see
his hand in front of his face let alone
have a sense of direction he stopped
moving
for two hours cuddling next to Balto and
the rest of his sled dogs he was hoping
that the storm would pass and they could
carry on however he could not stop
thinking about the children in the
hospital with every passing minute
another child could die without the
medicine and if he waited much longer
it was likely that they would not
survive the night he decided that his
only option was to move forward despite
not being able to see anything gonna
Carson had to put all of his faith in
his dog Balto dogs have a far better
sense of direction than humans and Balto
had been through the trail many times
before that always leading the way using
his senses to guide the rest of the team
to where they needed to go at one point
they were hit by a wind tunnel that was
so strong that it knocked over the sled
the medicine went flying into a large
snowbank Carson could not find it for a
very long time he got down on his hands
and knees and he started digging through
the snow before he finally found the
antitoxin Balto and the team they
finally reached in town called Port
Safety which was the next checkpoint in
the relay however he arrived in the
middle of the night and since the next
musher had been told the relay was
cancelled he and the dogs had fallen
asleep with just 12 miles left to go
Carson decided to push through the last
leg of the journey
self when they arrived back in Nome it
was 5:30 in the morning and he went
straight to dr. Welch once the vaccine
thought he was able to administer it to
the infected children and they were made
a full recovery soon after arriving back
in Nome journalists from all over the
United States began to contact Gunnar
Kaasen and asked for an interviews so
that they could hear the story of his
near-death experience bringing the
antitoxin to the Sick Children
he was always humble and downplayed his
involvement in securing the medicine he
said to the other drivers and dogs the
most credit is due there the harder mush
more difficulties for them I know I can
say as for myself we were glad to serve
Americans all over the country they
wanted to meet Balto and children loved
listening to the story of this real-life
dog hero Balto was invited to the
Biltmore Hotel in Los Angeles Ghana
Carson agreed to the interview and he
was shocked to see movie stars showing
up to have their picture taken with the
dog normally a national hero is welcome
to Los Angeles with keys to the city but
Balto was given the bones to the city
instead Paramount Pictures hired Balto
and gonna Carson to star in a dramatized
documentary called Balto's race to Nome
it became a blockbuster hit in 1925 they
made copies of the film but there was a
studio fire in the 1930s that destroyed
them all so sadly this movie no longer
exists they traveled by train across the
whole country and in December of 1925
they arrived in New York City Balto was
put on stage on Broadway for a week and
a vaudeville show he also posed for a
sculptor who created the brass statue
that stands in Central Park there was a
ceremony that unveiled the Balto statue
which included a plaque that said
dedicated to the indomitable spirit of
the sled dogs that relayed antitoxins
600 miles over rough ice across
treacherous waters through Arctic
blizzards from Nenana to the relief of
the stricken Nome in the winter of 1925
endurance fidelity intelligence even
though the statue was meant to
commemorate all of the 150 dogs it was
clear that Balto was the only one in the
limelight they announced Apollo was
still Balto's true owner but Gunnar
Carson was getting all of the credit
Cipolla he was jealous of this because
he had dedicated the majority of his
life to breeding and racing dogs he also
took the most risk during the journey by
volunteering for the most dangerous
portion of the trail by this logic he
thought that he would have
all of the glory and it was truly a low
blow for the least skilled musher and
dogs to get all of the attention not
only that but he also was angry that
Balto who he considered a subpar dog was
now representing the Siberian Husky
breed he believed that he and Togo
deserved to be on the front page not
those amateurs when he returned to Nome
Alaska after a year-long American tour
gala Carson found that Cipolla wasn't
the only one who was upset the community
was split between those who believed
Togo deserved the recognition and those
who supported Balto some even accused
Carson of skipping the last stop on
purpose because he would have known that
the sled two arrived in town with a
medicine would have gotten all the glory
but many historians do not believe that
Carson could possibly be motivated by
Fame
he would have had no way of knowing that
the whole country was waiting to hear
news about the small town in the middle
of Alaska he was simply too busy and
just trying to stay alive for Cipolla
the statue of Balto in Central Park it
was the last straw he wanted to get rid
of Balto and decided that he needed to
go on his own tour with Togo in an
attempt to brand him as the true dog
hero he and his manager they planned a
huge spectacle of traveling to New York
City to ride his team of dogs down
Broadway and end up at Madison Square
Garden but even on these tours children
they were still asking about Balto no
matter how hard he tried people still
loved the adorable black husky with
white socks that that is Masha through a
visit since they announced Apollo was
still batos legal owner he decided to
get rid of him for good by putting Balto
into the rest of the dog team up for
auction gala Carson was mortified and he
could not afford to bid on Balto to save
him from his fate
when Balto was sold Carson lost his best
friends and he was never the same again
Balto and the rest of the dogsled team
they were sold to a man named Sam
Houston who put them on display at his
dime Museum in Los Angeles these were
typically filled with oddities and freak
shows people paid a dime for a ticket to
go around and stare at the life
attractions the dogs were chained to the
wall all day every day they were not
allowed to run or to play and Houston
hardly fed them and they became sick
with mange in 1927 a man named George
Kimball from Cleveland Ohio was visiting
Los Angeles and he bought a ticket to
the Sam Houston dime Museum this is
where he found Balto Kimble had read all
of the stories in the newspaper so was
horrified to see these heroic dogs being
mistreated
he asked Sam Houston what it would take
to buy Balto and he was told that it
would take two thousand dollars after
modern-day inflation that's more like
$28,000 George Kimble could not afford
that himself so when he returned to
Cleveland he began a campaign to save
Balto the story of the dogs heroic
mistreatment it ran in the local
newspaper citizens of Cleveland donated
whatever they could afford even young
children brought their pennies to
Kimball's campaign hoping to save their
hero
ten days later they had raised enough
money to buy Balto
and they had a little extra leftover to
save his friends as well when the dogs
arrived in Cleveland's they were finally
allowed to pull a sled again as a team a
crowd of 15,000 people lined the street
sharing and giving the dogs a standing
ovation and the city it didn't stop that
citizens of Cleveland's they put
together the money to build the dogs a
large enclosure at the zoo with a grassy
field for them to run and play the
entire city considered them to be their
pets they were given more love and
attention than most dogs ever get Balto
remained at the Cleveland zoo for the
next six years when he was between 11
and 14 years old he became very sick and
he could barely walk when children heard
that he was missing from the grass
enclosure they would call the zoo every
day asking for updates to see if Balto
was feeling better but the veterinarians
they knew that it was more humane to put
him to sleep when Balto died the entire
country montt its death he was once
again on the front page of every paper
people loved him so much they didn't
want to let him go so
Balto his body it was turned into a
taxidermy figure his remains were moved
to the Cleveland Museum of Natural
History
ever since then children go on school
trips to see Balto and hear the story of
the race to save Nome for all his
efforts to erase Balto from history
separa
failed to insert himself and Togo into
the
Limelight's the extents that Balto had
been that Togo father dozens of puppies
and when he grew older he had a very
comfortable doggy retirement living with
a family friend and Poland spring Maine
when he died his body was also stuffed
and mounted at the Peabody Museum of
Natural History at Yale University
however it was never preserved properly
and children were touching and petting
Togo so much that the taxidermied figure
became damaged he eventually had to be
removed from the museum even after the
dogs had passed away there were still
plenty of people in the sledding
community who believed that Togo truly
deserved the fame over Balto but what we
do know for sure is that if it were not
for gunner Carson's complete trust in
his brave dog the entire team would have
frozen to death in their Blizzard the
vaccine for Nome would have been buried
under piles of snow and there is no
telling how many people would have died
as a result but what we do know is that
Balto the dog was a hero and certainly a
very good boy back in Alaska gonna
Carson lived a quiet life years later
his niece Janice Wayland asked her uncle
to tell her the story of what really
happens with Balto since she had had so
many different versions of the story
from children at school he replied I
will tell you this once and only once if
it wasn't for Balto and I wouldn't be
alive today so I really hope you found
that video interesting and inspiring if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe I've got brand new videos just
like this several times a week so hit
that subscribe button also the Belle
notification because the subscriptions
on YouTube they don't do what they used
to if you want to actually get a
notification where we put out a video do
hit that Bell and as always thank you
for watching
you
[Music]